and our next speaker beyond being this
repeat speaker four times now he's
passed the hat trick he's on to the four
pete
um
has been tossed around in the air so
much
and
it's ikedo he's being tossed around as
part of a japanese martial art you know
um unless he's like he's a stunt double
in a movie and we don't know about that
which would be kind of cool if you were
be very cool he's been tossed around so
much that he should get freaking flyer
miles for it
so
everyone please give a warm welcome to
objet
so today um i'm going to talk about
multilingual pipelines
um
language in terms of computer language
not in terms of you know the entire
conversation about english and spanish
um so one of the things that
i'm going to start off saying
i'm both an affiliate at georgetown and
i work at astrazeneca
both of which are in the dc area
standard disclaimer this stuff is
personal nothing to do with work
so if anyone's calling at work don't
fire me
so that the reason for this talk
the reason for this talk is that
i think pretty firmly that we are now in
a multilingual world as far as data
science is concerned
i don't think you can get away
with
just using one language
you might not use other language as well
but you can't get away with just using
one language and so i think that we are
actually in a place where we are
polyglots by necessity
and so there's a few ways that i have
used multiple languages um back in the
day when this is 10 years ago
when i got frustrated with r and how
long it took to load stuff into r
i used python to ingest data which was
faster and then used r for analysis this
was bioconductor stuff
and then arm are done for reporting
so that started me on this and this is
like way before the days of reticulate
or anything this is just literally
python it makes into a form then i can
use r to
take it over
um
some another path that i've used is i've
got data on databases and i use sql for
the munching and extraction and then r
for the analysis and that can entirely
be from art could be sql or separately i
know there's several of you who have
sort of
come from that this sort of background
coming from a database background then
learning r
for other stuff um typically
visualization
and this is the last one is something
that i'm actually doing right now it's
i'll talk about a little bit later in my
talk but it's using r for the data
ingestion and munching so how far we
have come that we went from not using r
for data ingestion and mudging to using
r for data industrial munching
and then using both r and python um
synergistically in a machine learning
pipeline
and then kicking it back out to r and
actually say r and python for
visualization
because certain things now especially
with the javascript stuff is better in
python than in r in terms of interfaces
so lots of different ways of doing this
and this is not the limiting thing you
can i know people who have sas and are
using r on the side from sas iml
um the entire sas via python thing is
happening
um but a lot of stuff from r so there's
a huge our javascript thing there's a
huge
um
obviously our python thing going on so
lots of multilingual
efforts going on
so
part of this is
based on use cases right and based on
where things are so the data is where it
is i'm not going to pull it out of my
sql database just because i need just
because i
you know can or need to um a lot of the
bioinformatics datasets that i work with
now are actually distributed as rds
files
or it could be on the web and i have to
download it
um this is becoming more and more of a
use case that the algorithms are
available in one language or the other
this is especially true for machine for
deep learning kinds of things which are
almost
entirely python based
um whereas a lot of the mundane
visualization reporting is r based
and so i'd rather not have to port
everything
to r
to do it rather you know have a good
product where it is
um
we can now decide which parts we want to
make speedy so certain things are faster
in certain languages than others
and even without going to the c plus
plus or julia or shell rouse there are
pieces you can do that will that will be
speedier than others depending on the
right tool
and
as uh i'm not starting a fight with the
sas folks even though you know it
happens
and i'm avoiding our java with a 20-foot
pole for this talk and really
in everything
you know our job has done better but i'm
still
not taking it
so
about this talk i'm not going to talk
about just data ingestion data ingestion
is an old problem we've sort of figured
it out
data's in different formats you can
either bring it to a common format or
just read it natively
uh haven't haven is a great one for the
sas folk we've got all the dbi based
stuff for databases hgtr for apis
there's stuff for json there's stuff for
excel so we've sort of gotten a pretty
good handle on this
but really actually running stuff
outside of our
but from r so r being the controller
that's sort of what i'm interested in
here
and so
there's a few connections that i use
this isn't by no means exhaustive um
this is just the tip of what i tend to
use um you guys
will probably do a lot more actually the
one connection that is not here that i'm
increasingly using is with javascript
um but there's databases there's stan
for those of you don't know that stan
logo there's that red big dot with the
sort of contrasted s in it python of
course
the shell sas and there's different
directionalities set r and python tend
to be bi-directional
stan tends to be i'm using stand to just
bring stuff into r
um and and so on but this is sort of my
ecosystem that i keep playing with
um
like i said this is each of you can have
your own and there's all sorts of
different players that you can put into
this
so
i know that people want to get too
articulate this particular is cool and
fun and so on but let's hold our horses
just talk about a little bit about some
of the other things that
we can use and i use um
i'm old as can be said by my the gray
hair on my beard so i still use the
shell and i know there's young people
use the shell too but i'm gonna just say
that because i'm old i keep using the
shell
um
so mark weissman who talked yesterday
and i teach a big data class at
georgetown
and one of the things we've actually
talked about a lot is that these kids
have to be taught the shell otherwise we
can't teach them big data on amazon
so shelf scripting is still important
um and it's available for everyone on
every platform now and
it's i think it's just as important as
it has been
but one of the things that shell and and
all of this stuff is
that people forget even though it's old
it's really efficient because it was
developed at a time when there was no
computer power you couldn't just throw
you know another two gpus at it
um so
these are really fast and really quick
not quick uis but they're quick
and so
you know everyone knows the shell the
system stuff in in our that's that's
people have used that i think more often
than not but the stuff that i actually
got excited about last year when i
discovered it is that you can actually
pipe a shell command into
an f read
for data table and so you can do some
pre-processing
um at the shell level before you even
put it into r
and it turns out that someone actually
benchmarked this
and
showed that you can actually something
have something a 15-fold reduction in
memory and three-fold increase in speed
by doing this
for a particular thing they were just
doing a grep uh just a search pattern
but this is really really useful so
first some things you can certainly do
set in awk and things like that which
are fast and just do things well and you
can just do the pre-processing there as
and keep things lighter in r
and um there's a suggestion i haven't
played around with as much as i should
but
there's also jnu parallel which can
allow some of this shell stuff to be
parallelized which makes things even
lighter and faster
um so
something just remind ourselves that you
know shell's still around and still good
and
and it does talk with r quite
beautifully actually so um something to
something you certainly think about
um databases are of course a very common
thing but not just for the data side but
we're actually using it to munch
using sql but still living in r so the
odbc world that we have
um
then the cool thing that happened i
think maybe five years ago now uh with
the with the db ply and
db player package and some other stuff
that our studio did
is that you can
do munging in a database
using dplyr syntax
which makes it
much easier so i don't have to remember
sql as much as i used to have so
not only can you
do
deep plier syntax to run stuff in
in an sql
database but you can also using the sqdl
sqldf library use sql to run stuff in r
so actually
it's really we can really be bilingual
here and i think this is a this is a
boon for everyone who's
you know come from sql and learningr or
have coming from r and having to learn
sql and i know several people who are
making that transition right now in a
corporate environment
and the fact that you can be bilingual
in this and take it either way is i
think is fantastic
um
this is sort of older not necessarily
brand new cutting edge stuff but but i
think i i use it enough that it's that
is that it's uh it's cool
so
given time i decided to choose my
battles here and so i'm
going off to reticulate and it took me a
while to understand why particularly was
named so until i found the picture so
vertically is another form of python
um i think many of you probably know
that but if you didn't now you know so
vertically just is is a cousin to
anaconda it's a cousin to python
so the big thing that vertically did
is it
allowed for a persistent python instance
to run alongside r there's always been
like little bits where you can just run
something into python have it put an
output into the onto your disk pull it
back in and then next time we do it it's
a new python session
reticulate keeps a persistent session on
which means you can
ping pong if you will you can do
something in r take it to python do
something in python bring it back to r
and so on and so forth
and that is useful in a lot of different
things and i have actually a use case
i'll talk about in a little bit um that
that goes to that
um just a side note for those of you in
python i'm
getting less and less fond of content
more and more fond of the traditional
pip
through poetry just works better and
faster for me
and you can use any of these virtual
environments in reticulate using the use
conde over the use virtual and
functions
so really quick
uh use case i know this is argov
and i used to write nih which was part
of a big part of gov
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
bioinformatics which is sort of 60 of
what i do now
um so we're looking at things called
single cell rna sequence analysis fancy
name basically says we have a way of
taking a sample separating out the cells
finding what the genes are in each cell
and trying to figure this out
because it's bioinformatics bioconductor
is the way people think
so r again
and so things like cirrht which are
which is more pure r based than
bioconductor
have already been out there they're
beautifully documented they're very
popular they're widespread
but there's an increased interest in
using deep neural networks and various
auto encoders to look at this kind of
complex data
um and i kid you not there's literally a
deep learning method of the week for
single cell rna data in nature or nature
genetics or data or nature methods or
one of those there's literally one every
week so it's like it's sprouting and
mushrooming and doing all sorts of
you know reproductive things in the
ether and so these methods are
leveraging tensorflow and torch and pyro
and
technologies that are sort of based in
python
and the thing is that both classes of
tools both the r group pipelines and the
python pipelines are actually quite
useful to gain biological insight in
different ways and you sort of want to
use the python bits to inform the arbits
and vice versa
so one of the things i've been working
on for the last year or so is creating a
pipeline the details aren't necessarily
important as to what the pieces are but
what is important is that there's
pipelines that are running in r and in
python in parallel they interact
and then they sort of merge at the end
to do sort of language agnostic stuff
and without particularly this really
can't happen
so this is something that um i've been
working on for for different purposes
over the past year and it's really
fascinating to see how well
uh sort of these these uh
co-lingual
pipelines um can be worked out now
so this is sort of what's motivated me
for a lot of this
um the other piece that motivates me in
this sort of multilingual world with r
is our markdown
and so i've become a big believer in
polyglot our markdown well for those of
you who didn't know our mark does
actually always been polyglot uh when
nature was written there were
um
chunks available or processors available
for over 45 languages
including some shell stuff some of our
competitors and sas and stata and the
like
um but so it's always been polyglot
but with reticulate you can actually
build because reticular keeps the python
on as you're doing things
and so i sort of took that to heart
early last year just before we were
going to lock down i was asked to teach
a
3d workshop in data science for with
python and i wrote the manual and the
manual was written in our markdown
but there's no r code in it it's all
python code
um this is open you know feminist
intersect and certainly some look around
but
the fascinating part of being able to
run do python an entire python book
essentially uh using our markdown
instead of doing jupiter and anything
else was really nice since i'm an r
first kind of person
and and this was just really really nice
and
with our mark down in our studio there's
you can do a lot of this sort of
multilingual things in our studio
there's now native support for six
different kinds of chunks
other than r
and so you can do a lot of stuff
internally so there's some stuff that we
were just teaching
um in our visualization class where
we're putting d3 into these markdowns
uh to create d3 graphics and the like so
there's a lot of stuff that's i think
really interesting and the ecosystem
sort of ripe for exploiting this now
between what our studio has what visual
studio code has
and what the capabilities are
are
um in terms of packages
so just leaving with some final thoughts
i think we've at a point where we've
sort of got the critical mass of coll of
connectors which are not doesn't don't
have to be jerry-rigged as much there's
actually packages so reticulate we've
talked about
uh rcpp the old you know the old nugget
julia culk gets to interact with julia
rxtender
works with rust r2d3 with d3
there's the entire html widgets group of
packages that connect with javascript
torch and keras are are packages that
that are using reticulate to connect to
the python versions
all tear i always laugh at because the r
package all tear is a reticulated
wrapper around the python package altair
which is the wrapper around javascript
package vega lite so it's like we're
using a three-step removed uh package
through like two translators
uh so that was sort of fun and then the
reticulate polyglot piece is i think
something i use a lot and i think it's
something worth thinking about for
publishing because i think the our
markdown book down
um blog down in ecosystem is a very
mature sort of data science and even
non-data science environment for
publication
and using sort of
these niche engines you can do stuff
that is not just r you can do a lot of
other stuff
so um and there's in the interest of
time of course i'll stop here
um
so
um thank you and i think i end up you
know bringing up the rear every year but
i still love it and
thanks for your time and hopefully next
we'll see each other in person